les sept moines français avaient été
enlevés dans leur abbaye le 27 mars
dernier depuis aucune nouvelle le
gouvernement français dément avoir
entamé négociations tout au plus
des contacts avaient été pris d assassin
affirment eux qu'ils avaient clairement
transmis au gouvernement français leurs
exigences dans une casse est parvenu à
l'ambassade de france à alger dominic
thiem authenticité probable crédibilité
totale
c'est ainsi que les autorités françaises
qualifie ce document attribué au gia il
annonçait hier l'assassinât des sept
moines trappistes enlevés le 27 mars
dernier en algérie
le communiqué précisait alors des
éléments jusqu'ici inconnue le 30 avril
96 lit-on dans le texte
un émissaire remettait à l'ambassade de
france à alger une cassette audio
prouvant que les moines étaient toujours
en vie cette information est aujourd'hui
confirmée par le quai d'orsay
il est exact qu'à cette date des
documents nous ont été adressées
documents faisant état du fait que les
religieux était encore en vie quelques
jours plus tôt le document audio remis à
l'ambassade de france a été enregistrée
le 20 avril en fond sonore un bulletin
d'information radio permet
d'authentifier cette date les moines
otages se présentent tour à tour
distinctement
si vous ne négociez pas dit il ils vont
nous tuer
ils reprennent aussi les termes du
communiqué publié deux jours plus tôt le
18 avril dans une rue proche du gia
les preneurs d'otages y exiger la
libération de prisonniers détenus en
france ainsi que celles d'abdelhak
layada un des chefs du génial
emprisonnés en algérie à paris pendant
deux mois
la direction de la sécurité du
territoire a été mobilisé le général
rondot expert aguerri a fait de nombreux
voyages en algérie
le dernier remonte à quelques jours mais
officiellement pas question de
négociation les contacts avaient été
pris
j'ai ri mais il n'y a pas eu de
négociations il ne peut pas y avoir de
négociation
comment voulez vous qu'on envisage un
seul instant de négocié avec des
assassins aussi barbare stupeur affirmé
tiers le premier communiqué des
autorités françaises le mot était
choisie apparemment rien ne laissait
entrevoir l'imminence d'une issue
tragique
[Musique]